members before the before the meeting
proper starts I'll just read out the
emergency evacuation announcement should
we be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building via
the nearest available exit to the
chamber our assembly point will be in
the public car park at the side of the
Civic suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded and my
may I also remind members to ensure that
their mobile phones are switched off all
on mute thank you
members will you please be upstanding to
receive the Chairman the Chairman's
chaplain and the managing director can
we remain standing while we have our
prayers thank you today is true Tuesday
day before Ash Wednesday and it's a day
in the church calendar where everyone
feasts before they moments for the next
40 days of changing perhaps their
thoughts or their thinking it's the
beginning of the season where we are
able to reflect and ponder our life it
is a season where we can focus within
the church calendar on the death and
resurrection of Christ and it's a time
where those who are not part of church
also spend time reflecting in what they
are going to do for a season a period of
time to reassess their values to
reassess their actions their beliefs to
look back and then also to look forward
to review their thinking and this
evening you gather to make decisions
that will impact and change and
challenge and transform the communities
and the individuals that you represent
and this evening we come before Almighty
God let us pray
we thank you for the weather father God
outside for the challenges that that
brings in this season we thank you for
the rain it brings change we ask Lord
that you will be present amongst this
gathering this evening in the decisions
that are made may there be a sense of
oneness for the communities that are
represented and for the impact the
decisions are made here have in the
people of the district we ask these
things in the name of Christ you may sit
I just want to remind people that the
microphones are working but we can't
have more than two on at a time so after
you finish speaking can you please turn
your microphones off thank you item 1
apologies for absence
we received apologies for councilor
autumn and councillor FD are there any
others a chairman councillor kennel is
slightly delayed on the train at the
moment but he he does show me there
he'll be alone okay thank you sorry
sorry chairman Eric councillor Cooper
relief he's got work I mean Stacy I
thank you very much
any others item two to receive
declarations of interest are there any
item three the medium-term financial
strategy 2018 19 to 2022 23 Thank You
chairman the the title of the item that
you read out as it does on the surface
sound a little bit drab but it it does
hide the content of what is a very
important document there is a huge
amount of work that has gone into this
there's many pages and some appendices
that take quite some time to go through
just to look at and then when you look
at each item and get an understanding of
the the work that is behind the
calculations and the the statement so
there you get you get an understanding
of just what an important document this
is clearly at the heart of it is the
council tax and if I can move straight
to that one first please chairman there
is a rise in council tax which equates
to six pounds 48 a year for a ban
and D property and I'll immediately be
happy to move that one for the vote when
that comes in due course the other items
with the exception of the last one which
refers to appendix item 3-1 the appendix
which would like further discussion
about please I'm quite happy to agree
and move those on block just a few
general words before I pass over to the
section 1 501 officer who's done the
majority of the work with her team to
flesh out the detail I think that the
statements and the the resolutions that
we've got there in front of us
underpinned the efficient and prudent
management of the council which has been
taking place this year and in past years
and is set for the future as well
provides the basis of innovative
investments and exciting projects for
the residents of Rochford district the
general reserves are at the sit for
guidelines and the state the resolutions
do meet the council objectives that's
all I wanted to say at this point
chairman so I'll now be happy to pass
over to the section 1-5 on officer flesh
out the detail thank you
I think is sorry can you hear me and
okay so yeah this evening I'm presenting
to you the medium-term financial
strategy for the council including the
proposed budget for 1819 as members will
be aware the council has a statutory
duty to set a balanced budget for the
new financial year and the reports that
sound a number of proposals which will
enable us to do so whilst continuing to
deliver against our business plan
priorities members will be more than the
way that local government has faced an
unprecedented period of funding pressure
since 2010 and this looks set to
continue for at least the medium term
central government has placed increasing
reliance on local authorities to raise
revenues locally rather than to rely on
grant income Rochford will lose all of
its revenue support grant funding from
1819 this is a reduction of 1.2 million
since 1516 and it faces a potential
financial cliff edge from 1920 when
there's a proposed implementation at one
point sorry of nor point 6 million
negative RSG coupled with considerable
financial pressures that the council's
facing with regard to increased demand
for services including statutory duties
around homelessness and rising inflation
this gives rise to projected gap of
around 1.8 million by 2020 20 22 23
the council has taken significant steps
to start addressing the projected gap
and as already identified 1 million of
future proposals including efficiency
savings and income to help its continued
its journey towards financial
sustainability in future years the
revised program of work has been in
green and so a revised program work has
now been agreed in principle by the
council's Investment Board was one of
the key deliverables be deliverables
being ideas that will help to meet the
future financial gap
I'm moving back to the position for 1819
the provides budget has been drawn up
with consultation with key stakeholders
including senior officers members and
members of the public as referred to
earlier there are a number of key
pressures that we are facing over the
next financial year including rising
inflation increased demand for services
and in addition we will require some
investment in staffing to maintain
business critical areas although careful
consideration has been given to all of
those proposals with all staffing
proposals being held for six months to
identify whether they are truly required
overall pressures in the budget for 1819
were around 1.3 million in order to
address those we have identified 850
thousand pounds of efficiency savings
and new income items from across the
portfolio areas in addition is around
250,000 pounds of growth in the council
tax base and business rates this leaves
the remaining 200,000 pounds and gap
still to find which is councillor Smith
referred to is proposed to be met
through an increase of two point nine
eight percent in accounts of tax this
equates to around twelve pence per week
for an average bandi property moving on
to the capital program for 1819 and this
is mainly around enhancement of the
council's the existing assets however
there's the intention through the
council's Investment Board that a
program of long term investment projects
will be identified and those will be
built into the capital program at a
future date once I've been agreed by a
council the proposed 1819 capital and
treasury management strategy sets out
the parameters and indicators under
which that work would be undertaken miss
councillor Smith said those we plans
maintain a general balance of around ten
percent of the net revenue budget and
this is considered prudent in order to
maintain a contingency any events of
unexpected or emergency costs that could
arise during the course of the year
the council also proposes to maintain
its strategy of transferring its new
homes bonus monies into an interest
infrastructure reserve for investment
projects while this does mean that
councils projected level of reserves is
set to increase slightly over the
medium-term pending agreement of
investment projects through the
Investment Board and the council's
levels of overall earmark reserves
remain at the lower end of comparable
local authorities and are therefore not
considered to be excessive particularly
given the climate of financial
uncertainty that the council is now
facing so in summary I would say that
the medium-term financial strategy has
been prepared against the backdrop of
significant funding reductions and
financial challenges these factors could
jeopardize the council's sustainable
financial position unless continued
budget savings efficiencies and income
streams are delivered over the
medium-term in relation to the papers
that you've got in front of you I'd like
to draw your attention to just a couple
of specific points that varies and since
the papers were published firstly the
local government finance settlement and
the final settlement has now been
published by governments and that
confirmed the level of funding set out
in the papers and has not changed since
the provisional settlement I would also
like to make correction to align in
appendix two within the detailed budgets
for homelessness under council web
support folio where an income line
called removals and storage income
should in fact read rental income from
22 South Street there's a further small
correction in relation to Appendix 3s
fees and charges for environmental
services and where a couple of lines are
showing an increase where in fact all
fees will be how flats in in next
financial year and therefore should show
zero percent increase and finally the
council's review committee met on the
6th of February considered the capital
and treasury management strategy which
is appended to this report the minutes
of that meeting form part of the council
papers that you've got tonight the
review committee did recommend that the
strategy should be recommended to full
council subjects of an adjustment to the
wording of section 9 of the strategy and
the removal of the option for into
authority lending from the council's
proposed lending list so I would just
advise members that they would should
bear in mind the Review Committee's
recommendation when agreeing the
recommendation within the MTFs reports
so unless there's any specific questions
that members would like to ask out refer
back to the chair to agree the
recommendations in the report yeah we've
got a proposal on the floor do we have a
seconder for that for the council and
that's for the first six recommendations
then separately the increase in the
council tax and then the next six but
not the last one is that correct yes so
well it point number six has to be
approved by a recorded vote so we'll
take that one now bullet point number
six the increase in Rochford district
council tax two point nine eight percent
to eight thousand and 1819 be approved
by recorded vote
yeah sorry counselor Mason nice feet
sorry my post-it notes are getting
confused yes counselor cut more than
counselor Mason and then counselor hook
bye Thank You chairman I always follow
your directions chairman a brilliant
budget I think we have a clear prudent
section of government within our own
authority that actually looks after our
residents and looks after our pennies as
well debt pounds but we have challenges
chairman from this year in other words
next civic year we'll have no revenue
support grant whatsoever and indeed
within a short time after that its
motives that we shall have negative
revenue support grant so we have
significant challenges coming forward
one thing we do chairman of the council
is the new homes bonus that we receive
which has also been reduced because it's
down to four years worth instead of five
years worth so it's been top sliced
we put aside to make sure that we a
cover ourselves and B we use that
through investments again a prudent
measure that we take forward I believe
chairman from the surveys that been done
in the past and present there we have
highly regarded services and I'm
constantly hearing about that from our
residents yes we're not perfect in every
way
but we get very good services delivered
by our officers and I'm very mindful of
the fact that they are delivering that
with a lower workforce again which is a
prudent measure going forward
Jim we have no borrowing whatsoever none
so we're not paying interest we're not
paying back capital of course we may use
that in the future but it's something
that I think is sort of synced stayed in
the past but we need to make sure that
if we do borrow we borrow prudently and
for the right thing and for investment
that will bring forward dividends for
both the council and of course our
residents but through that prudent use
of our resources when we've had to for
instance for homelessness when we had to
provide some extra funds this year to
make sure that we accommodated the vast
increase in homelessness that I think
walking out sort of actually experienced
we had that money aside to be able to
carry that forward but one other thing
we're doing which I think we've already
mentioned is we're investing in our own
assets and making sure we exploit them
accordingly so I think cat carrying
ourselves forward these are the right
policies that will bear fruit into the
future it's not an instant thing you
can't get money straight away from it
from that sort of investment but it does
mean that we will get extra income that
we can use towards the resources that we
need to deliver good services one thing
that we've done is course is to
establish a lack of a local authority
trading company and the great gateway
has been a successful year it's turned a
profit and I think it's also
establishing itself as one of the main
businesses delivering those services in
the authority it's certainly working
along with other parishes and even being
looked at by it by other councils as
both an example when actually maybe
using our services - one thing I think
and it was touched on by it by a
five-run officer is about the fees all
their fees chairmen are saying the same
you know increased any of them and that
includes parking so we've managed to
hold that steady as well so that covers
back covers for those fees that are paid
by our residents
indeed we've actually employed more
staff in areas that we know are under
pressure we've actually put aside I
think 163,000 odd so make sure that
we're actually covering those areas
where we think there are pressures
within the council and I think there's
too many councils that do that either
we've actually had found the money to be
able to do that because we are prudent
chairmen so I think that prudent budget
that we have will carry us into the
future yes of course we're going to have
our challenges and yes we look at
chuckling a modest prize modest rise in
our council tax preset 12 pence a week
for a bandy property chairman less if
you've got a lower bounding than that
which I think most accountant most
people would be able to afford indeed
probably not even notice but having you
said that chairman there will be other
increases as well we send the bills out
but of course we look responsible for
all of it so chairman going forward I
think we've proved that we have a track
record of running a very prudent counsel
and I'm very proud of our record on that
and I think they'll stand by a record
thank you Jim
Thank You councillor mr. Mason Thank You
chairman the first thing I'd like to do
is Thank You Lucas for answering a
fairly long list of questions by myself
and my members so thank you very much I
want to talk this evening about some
principles and principles we seem to
have missed out on but before that I
just like to remind this council that
the challenges of no RSG and negative
RSG have been actually imposed by a
Conservative government I can't have
always saying that chairman because
that's where it is so the challenges we
face have been imposed upon us chairman
I'm only here because residents elect me
and that goes same for everyone else
that's here so everything I think about
these residents
the council shouldn't make it difficult
for residents to understand budget
proposals and form of you themselves
it's not just for us sitting here as
elected people to make those decisions
on their behalf but I take the view that
I want to consult with them I want them
to give me a view of how they would like
me to actually conduct myself and vote
so I've been very disappointed that
residents who might have wanted to read
this empty of this document this year
had to go and consult with a previous
year's report to get detail on how the
council the detail chairman of how the
council might close a gap of something
around 1.8 million in fact I had a
message from a resident at 6 o'clock
this morning so I don't speak of
something that supply in the sky this is
something that really happens do I
really have to go and read prior-year
reports to find out the detail of how
that 1.8 million may be closed and that
includes the sort of thing that does
involve I'm afraid things like car
parking charges and maybe other new
charges which I've been very surprised
haven't been elucidated in this current
report chairman raising council tax to
the maximum required before a referendum
is needed is not it's not a modest
increase I've just heard this is a
modest increase it's the maximum okay
two point nine eight versus three the
maximum that this council could have
increased council tax by without having
a referendum residents who have
contacted me say that it's not is not
modest many of them speak about not
receiving that sort of pay rise
themselves so I'm afraid they do see
this as an imposition
and they really aren't very keen on it
at all
and I don't think they're going to be
very accepting the other thing they're
not going to be accepting about is we're
putting 50% of their nearly a hundred
thousand straight into reserves but as
they put it to me there's no specific
project no specific benefit for
residents that's been identified nor any
specific service that it's actually
going to be improved and again they tell
me this is not going to find favor with
then-chairman we know about the
investment board it's been in place for
some time but the figures and all the
major projects are all in exempt and
because of that residents don't know
really much about what our policy and
strategy is and they deserve some detail
apart from being told surely we are
going to exploit what the framework
exploits our assets and we're going to
generate some welcomed income I think
they deserve a bit more than that after
the length of time that this investment
boards been running and I can't tell
them tonight or at any time how much the
investment board is currently spent and
what the yield is currently on that
Chairman I can't support this budget
because I believe that we've not
informed residents sufficiently to carry
them with us and we need to carry
residence with us because frankly that's
who we serve we shouldn't forget we're
not hearing at some sort of financial
bubble we are in here to represent them
in relation to the most local economy
you can imagine chairman I want to also
talk about the last item in the
recommendation
I don't believe the chairman of review
will get the opportunity to speak this
evening as he would do if he was
presenting any minutes but our reports
here so I do chairman want to put to you
so you know I want to recorded votes on
the last item on the recommendation
which relates to the treasury management
report and the recommendations our
review committee chairman just a few
points so I can remind members and
particularly those who weren't a review
committee just what the points were
being made the council is never linked
to local authorities before and I and I
and I actually can't think why it now
become something that we're very
interested in doing the officers only
became aware for premium rates interest
rates being available from local
authorities in December now they've been
at great pains to point out to review
committee that they've always had this
ability this power this delegation to
lend to a local authority so what I
don't quite understand is if it was such
a great deal and they were really very
happy about it why didn't they lend some
money to a local authority in December
why did they wait to talk to a new
committee why did they wait for review
for this lead to make a CID decision on
the treasury management strategy that
they wanted to put forward to full
council but since then chairman there
has been critical focus on local
authority finance both by the DC og and
the eventual financial press we know
about North Hampton and the financial
press and the IT LG IU is talking about
other councils having similar issues
so what are we likely to earn out of
this additional risk because you can't
credit you can't do a credit analysis of
a local authority you can look at the
last two balance sheets
but I'm going to put it to you look most
of them have the investment strategy is
in exempt so how will you know what's
going on in other councils we won't and
I don't know what that risk is and nor
do you and nor will our officers so how
much would we earn by taking additional
risk we learn another six thousand
pounds per annum ease for a whole year
or sixteen pounds per night I can't see
any reason chairman at this point while
this situation of difficult difficult
financial circumstances for local
authorities why we should want to take
that risk if it's not financial and I
did read but it's not financial and I
can't think of the reason that we might
not we might wish to take that risk
perhaps someone would like to tell me
what they think that other reason other
than financial return might be I'm not
going to be voting against the
recommendations our review committee
chairman as I say I'm looking forward to
having a recorded vote on the issue
thank you Thank You councillor Hook why
thank you madam chairman
I think encountered real Masons probably
stolen some of my son because there's a
couple of things that I might mention
which he is covered what I will say is
that it's been widely reported that 95
percent of local authorities in England
and Wales hmm are going to be raising
council tax this year so on the basis of
that it's not a surprise that this
budget has been put forward in the
recommendation in it and bearing in mind
the gap for which we are looking to try
to narrow that I want to reiterate what
cancel Mason's stated and that is now a
fact and a fact that our local residents
are now starting to realize and see that
there is a direct relationship between
reduction in funding from central
government and increases in their
council tax because it is the reduction
in money coming from central government
that he's forcing councils across the
country to increase the council tax on
them and I think that when people say
that we are only asking for a small
increase most people's incomes are
limited by the lack of increase in in in
wage increases and particularly affects
low low income people who may be on
fixed incomes so it is in that the area
that we we need to think about what we
are intending to do and how it affects
more vulnerable residents and that's all
I've got to say on this matter at this
time thing Thank You council Newport
Thank You chair as councillor Mason and
council hope we have already mentioned I
understand that the council's under
pressure to deliver the services that
our residents have come to expect with
the funding removed by central
government and this council taking the
opportunity to shift costs to town and
parish councils such as in the case of
the toilets and playgrounds it still
remains a challenge to close that budget
deficit I however do not think I could
support this budget tonight when I hear
their solution is a rise in the council
tax which I believe is excessive the
council tax rise gives the surplus
revenue which will be put into reserves
these reserves have been used to offset
some poor management in projects such as
the ICT with double the original budget
has been spent the council needs to work
harder to make sure that these types of
projects are delivered on time and
within budget in the future I do not
think our residents should be made to
pay for the the council's mistakes in
and poor project management at a time
when their own household budgets are
being stretched without increase in
their own incomes Thank You councillor
mrs. Mason
thank you madam chairman I suppose it
won't surprise you to know that I agree
with everything counselor place and
mistake and also the other leaders of
the opposition however I'm going to
focus on the recommendation that's come
forward from the review committee
because that is a matter I think of
concern and I'm aware but not everyone
was available so listen till the very
lengthy and involved debate that took
place it is of concern that the
information on rates interest rates
given to the review committee and quoted
at 1.9 with report I to 3-1 were
ascertained to be incorrect after the
meeting according to further information
from the section 1 5 1 officer this rate
was altered on the 2nd of November but
not acted upon until after the review
meeting last week I leave you to draw
your own conclusions on that we were
advised that there were three main
criteria applied to investments and I'm
sure we all apply them ourselves in our
day-to-day life with our own personal
bonus but for the sake of clarity
they are security liquidity and the
interest rate which is the return on
risk
there is no objective measurement of
security when lending to another local
authority there is absolutely none the
only information we can get is historic
or is is hidden with regards to
liquidity we've all seen in the press
that this is very uncertain and there's
speculation of vales
that it will be illiquid and the return
of risk was not as stated we were told
that it was a differential between
naught point 2 and naught point 6
percent the actual differential was
between naught point four and nine point
six percent pursuing the next note point
six percent is correct I haven't checked
that one that's a hundred percent over
this extra risk could up would offer a
relatively small increased rate of
return but as it has taken a rupture
District Council over three months to
notice and react to a rate change such
an investment strategy could be very
risky this reason I support the amended
recommendation the recommendation from
the review committee and not the
original recommendation and I'm hope
that this council sees the need to be
prudent at this time thank you
hence the step time Thank You chair um
mmm the question of the projects that
the investment board are looking at
being all in exempt is incorrect there
are at least three projects that spring
to my mind that are in the public domain
and in coating in a couple of cases they
certainly have been through consultation
and they've been on public display the
third has actually been through the
planning committee so those three
projects are well established in the
public domain
they're 57 South Street 19 South Street
and a smaller project over in stand
bridge so I just like to correct and
remind members that not all the projects
are in exempt thanks Jeff councillor
mister hi
thank you madam chairman and it will
probably be no surprise that I also
cannot support the increase in council
tax there's a few things I just want to
go through to start with you've talked
about trust this administration as has
already been said we're trusting them
with 3.2 million in a hard soft
infrastructure fund which has no detail
you see interesting that councillor
Steptoe said that some of these projects
are not an exempt can he please confirm
could he now say in public what the
costs and estimates for those projects
are can he give returns on capital on
those projects I don't think he can cuz
I believe those are in exempt and we
cannot talk about them if I am wrong I'm
happy to apologize to him personally on
that with regard to trust with we're
talking about it increasing council tax
which raises two hundred thousand pounds
for this council two hundred and two
thousand plus a few other pounds I
believe I know this has already been
said by Diamond Lucas that he that
bridges the gap however this is one of
the other problems with this budget in
the executive summary we have at six
point five the total budget gaps before
savings efficiency is eight point four
five million in six point six savings
and efficiencies are eight point five
million that seems to me to close the
budget gap I understand the figures that
were given to us in the meeting and that
is presented slightly differently to
that but when the executive summary
actually says we've closed the graphic
magic gap with efficiencies and savings
that means the two hundred thousand
pounds is going directly into reserves
again back to trust that's the new pool
mention about the transfer of reserves
for ICT projects we are asked to trust
you but then last year they were two
hundred sixty four thousand pounds which
is in the accounts transferred from a
reserve into a capital budget because we
trusted the administration I will leave
that there thank you
councillor Smith Thank You chairman if I
can talk about the the treasury
management strategy plays there's the
recommendation on 3.1.3 I've got no
problem with the the changing and the
adjustment to the paragraphs that are
mentioned but I'm not in favor of the
removal of the option of intra thority
lending and I'll move that that is left
in the strategy we have a strategy that
has on the whole being accepted with it
with that that that's small correct
alteration and the proposed removal of
lending to other authorities the
strategy itself outlines a wide range of
ways in which this council will invest
money the way in which the council has
the money to invest is a nature of how
it works it's not that we sit on large
reserves that aren't earmarked for
specific projects it's that we handle a
lot of money for a lot of other
authorities in particular Essex and that
money won't always come in in even-even
streams and from time to time over
weekend's over bank holidays even
overnight we will have amounts of money
belonging that about going to be paid to
other authorities but it's sitting in
our account and it's only prudent and
wise that we invest it sensibly so that
we can maximize our assets we have our
priorities in the policy of security and
liquidity and they underpin everything
we do we're not seeking for the
permission to simply change all of our
investment policy
to loaning to other councils overnight
this is just one of a wide range of
investments that we would like to have
in as an option to be used or not used
as the case may be and that case may be
based on professional advice it will be
based based on research it will be based
on investigation clearly counsels not
financial institutions and they they
need to be looked at in a different way
but there are plenty of financial
institutions that have their problems
and we choose not to invest with them we
know that councils work under sit for
guidance we know that they have strict
audits we know that they have plenty of
public documents available for
examination no investment would be
undertaken without meeting the test of
security and liquidity I think it's fair
to trust the officers professional
opinion to sit down to examine what
their options are and if on whatever
occasion it happens to be an investment
in another council for a period that
work within the strategy is appropriate
then they should have the flexibility to
do that to maximize the assets that we
have available to us we've heard a
number of members here tonight say that
how they understand how challenging this
situation is I'm chairing a meeting this
coming Monday on handing out some some
grants to some of our local charities
and residents making money from
investments helps provide the resource
to do these things so I'm happy to move
that the investment policy should
include the option the ability to invest
in other councils as appropriate
the little bit about paragraphs I'm not
too fussed and I'd be happy to support a
call for a recorded vote on that one
thank you
councillor mate
chairman I'm even more alarmed and I was
review committee let me explain
I heard that we receive and I know that
we receive monies through the council
tax demands on behalf of other
precepting organisations including the
largest one Asus Canada Council and
increasingly the police so we are
proposing to use their money and place
that with other local authorities
Chairman I I don't sure how prudent
betty's I don't know whether they will
consider that to be very prudent I think
we ought to ask their permission to use
their money to earn interest which ends
up in our coffers I think there's
something a little wrong if I remember
rightly when I was a parish council and
that was a long long time ago on to
bearish councils the parish councils
have the opportunity to take the whole
of their precept in one amount
immediately after receipt of the precept
presumably the other authorities can
also take lump sums from the preset
rather than leave it all with watch the
District Council that's what I
understand but my particular concern is
having money from other all authorities
on whose behalf we have raised money and
placing that into what I consider to be
potentially a risky sector Chairman I
must reiterate
you can look at to last year's balance
sheets but you don't know anything else
you don't know anything about the
business cases behind their investment
portfolios if they're in exempt like our
Council
I don't want our offices to be placed in
that invidious position an invidious
position which having had some
experience in lending any institutional
markets
I wouldn't wish to take at this point in
time so for those of us that choose to
vote and not abstain I would say think
very carefully about what we're voting
to do and what we're voting to do with
other people's money thank you chairman
thank you madam chairman and thank you
for allowing me to come back when I
spoke earlier I didn't mention about the
last item in relation to what will come
up before review and what review
committee had quite an extensive
discussion about this this this was this
were was a meeting that that did go
through they seem quite can some
considerable detail and there was quite
a range of opinions that were put
forward I would I would think it you
know members should should consider that
you know the review committee has had
the opportunity to read through this and
take some careful considerations and
quiz our financial officers about what
they have been proposing is interesting
that this is something that has been a
option that has not been used in the
past and is interesting that it's being
considered at the moment when local
authorities as we won't know for our for
ourselves are under considerable
financial strain and that may lead to
some poor decision making taking place
in other local authorities because there
is no credit rating system available to
make an assessment of the viability of
an investment with another local
authority and how safe it is and what
the risk is with regard to that it was
considered by a number of members of the
re committee that that may be a risk
that is too much to take at this time
we are looking to invest in as something
that is going to be riskier the returns
are going to be potentially higher
because the interest rate on that return
is shown to shown to be higher but that
is just an example of showing that it is
a riskier option thank you madam
chairman all right Thank You members and
we have a proposal that didn't see
counselor ward
thank you very much madam Speaker
isn't that interesting
I'm in the wrong place I'm in the wrong
place for years Great Expectations I
think madam chairman madam chairman I
found it was very very interesting that
he bite that that has carried on this
evening and I found that the arguments
being put forward some of which are
rather strange I have to say and
especially the arguments regarding
council tax receipts being used to
invest in other authorities and I think
that's a huge red herring massive
absolutely ridiculous I mean we have an
extremely prudent counsel that have
operated in a way over the years which
has proved that we are one of the only
councils in the United Kingdom that is
totally debt-free
so the illusions that are being created
by gentlemen on the rear benches are
crazy I am but it feels like it
yeah I know thank you very much I think
that this item that has been highlighted
by members with regard to what is going
on just shows exactly what a good budget
we have put forward and and the reason
is the members of the Opposition have
found this is the only thing that they
can bring to this chamber as an item of
criticism because quite frankly I think
that is false as well we need to have
the options available to be able to
invest in any way we need to and of
course we have been prudent we have
never invested in authorities before and
there's nothing to say we may not do it
in the future but that is a decision
that is down to our one five one
officers in regards to sensible
investments so I totally refute the
illusion that I'm afraid the members of
the Opposition have put forward and I
support councillor Smith in his motion
thank you thank you I'll get back to
where I was we have a proposal for the
recommendations apart from the sixth
bullet point and the last bullet point
where we've had the debate can we take
the those a real agreement to take those
on block apart from the sixth bullet
point and the last bullet point
you stand up guys yeah but I am asking
if we can take these on block apart from
the six bullet point which has to be a
recorded vote separately and the last
ones yes all right
okay thank you so we need a recorded
vote please
so the first five bullet points the
first five to start with
I wanted to to Germany it's off of six
in the final crime all of them apart
from the sixth one and the final one yes
we found on them yeah we're going to
vote on these and it will be a recorded
vote
cancel hook why what did you want to
sign
he do that yeah okay clarify
chairman thank you could I could I first
be be clear that the request on your
behalf that the request for a recorded
vote
relates to agreement to all the bullet
points apart from the sixth one which
has to be taken separately and the final
one in in that case chairman just just
to clarify if if members would like to
turn to page three point two four of the
paper with the recommendations it would
be about the first five bullet points
net revenue budget requirement be set at
nine point eight nine to six million
capital program proposed methods for
couple expenditure to be approved the
section one five one officer being
authorized to adjust capital project
budgets in 2018-19 throughout the
program after 2017 18 accounts are
closed and amounts of slippage and
budget carry forward required unknown
noting that the proposed council tax
requirement for the counters own purpose
excluding precepts from parish and towns
is 7 million and the draft equivalent
banty tax base being based on thirty one
thousand two hundred ninety seven
properties the schedule of fees and
charges for 2018-19 be as per appendix
three the general balance being set at
naught point eight eight four million
pounds as at first of April 2018 in mark
reserves being as per the table in
section 14 of the section one five one
officers report the statement on the
robustness of the estimates and reserves
at section 14 of the one for one of his
report being noted the summary of the
Equality impact assessment as set out in
section 12 this report being noted and
finally it being noted that the final
local government finance settlement
isn't expected until early February and
any change resulting for
that will be issued and tabled at the
budget meeting there was nothing to
introduce in that in that regard members
the recorded vote is in relation to
those recommendations thank you before
we carry on councillor Mason I have
noticed that you've wanted to speak but
we have we are now taking a vote on this
fair enough yes
[Music]
[Music]
all right so cancer cut more just to
remind members that the section one five
one over some mentioned appendix to
about the twenty-two South Street the
and about appendix three the
Environmental Services charges so I
think we need to note that because those
appendices were changed we take the
recorded vote now place councillor
Burton can't son mrs. butcher before
can't silicon l-cancel apart-er
cancer to cut more councillor Dre cancel
it herbs
counselor mrs. Gooding counselor Griffin
counselor hazlewood counselor hook way
counselor mrs. hoi counselor
hoi
counselor mrs. Hughes counselor you are
new counselor Lucas Gill Califano mrs.
Lumley counselor Christine Mason
counselor Elliot Mason counsel of John
Mason counselor mirik or counsel a meal
counts in a mountain
councillor Newport
can't Salah mrs. Rowe
counselor mr. Shaw counselor Smith
councillor sparing
can't sort of Stanley
can't sort of step toe plants an award
for counts on a web counselor mrs.
Weston councillor Williams councillor
Wilson
so they are yeah
Thank You chairman that was agreed 22
for 4 against 9 abstention now chairman
council needs to turn to recommendation
bullet point 6 that needs to be agreed
through recorded vote if I could invite
Michelle to thank you
councillor Burton can't so mrs. butcher
for Kant silicon al
cants anakata
can't summer cut more councillor Dre
councillor EBEs
counselor mrs. Gooding can't sell a
Griffin counselor he's the would cancel
hoc way
councillor Dianne hoy
councillor Michael hoy counselor mrs.
Hughes counselor you are no plants alert
Lucas Gill counselor mrs. Lumley
counselor Christine Mason counselor
Eliot Mason counselor John Mason
counselor Merrick counts in a meal
counts in a mountain
cancel a Newport
counselor mrs. Rowe counselor mrs. Shaw
councillor Smith councillor sparing
can't sort of Stanley councillor Steptoe
councillor Ward or cancel a web
counselor mrs. Weston councillor
Williams councillor Wilson
so
Thank You chairman that was carried 22
for 13 against now chairman returned to
the final bullet point in the
recommendations there has been there is
a motion on the table
that's the recommendation of the review
committee be agreed apart from a change
to the inter Authority lending aspect so
the motion is now that into Authority
lending is included as an option in the
proposed lending list for 2018-19 so
that's the motion chairman the will as a
technicality need to be at least seven
members standing for that to be taken by
recorded vote thank you
okay thank you
so I now invite Michelle to take the
recorded vote thank you
councillor Burton counselor mrs. butcher
for that sort of canal councillor Carter
counselor cut more counselor Dre
counselor EBEs counselor mrs. Gooding
counselor Griffin counselor Hazlewood
counselor hoc way counselor Diane hoy
not sort of Michael boy count sir mrs.
Hughes
counselor you are new counselor Lucas
Gill counselor mrs. Lumley counselor
Christine Mason counselor Elliot Mason
counselor John Mason yes can't sell
AmeriCorps counsel a meal canceled a
mountain canceled a Newport
counselor mrs. Rowe counselor mrs. Shaw
counselor Smith cancer despairing can't
sort of Stanley counselor step toe
councillor Ward council a web counselor
mrs. Weston councillor Williams
councillor Wilson
thank you Jim
that was carried 21 for 14 against and
that concludes that agenda item chairman
thank you thank you we now move to item
four and the agenda and that's the
exclusion of press and public is that
agreed members